your life begins now Aladdin so I am
here at Disney with Meena Massoud he is
the star of Aladdin I can't tell you how
much excited I am about this thing I
think a lot of people are excited about
I hope so and this has been a long
journey getting to this point for you
yes but I want to go back to the magic
carpet ride that was your audition okay
yes from sort of if you could sort of
take me a little bit through it from the
moment like when you heard they were
casting a Lattimore you like I know I
mail this or was it kind of like oh I
don't have a shot and sort of take me
through how many auditions and then the
moment you found out you got it yeah
they were doing a general casting call
that I'm sure a lot of people saw online
and whatnot and I reached out to my
agents and you know I said I think I'd
be right for this I grew up watching it
obviously a lot and then we didn't hear
anything back after my first tape for
quite a while and I kind of let it go as
actors tend to do and as you have to do
and then four months later we heard back
Wow about the tape that I had done and
they asked me to do another tape so I
did another one and then things started
ramping up I flew to London for a week
to test the first time this is with Guy
Ritchie this is guy ritchie yes and the
creative team and then i flew back to
toronto actually to our hometown to
finish up a film i was working on and
then flew back to london a second time
to test a second time and then flew back
to toronto and because I would have at
one point just timed out and been like I
can't handle the pressure give it to
somebody out here did you stay sort of
calm and focus did you just sort of
immerse there a moment when you were
auditioning that you kind of said oh I
think I got it yeah I think I think when
you've tested before and kind of have
gone through that you you learn how to
accept not getting it so I think I was
just very grateful to have been given
the opportunity to even get that far and
I knew that they were
they had been auditioning for quite a
while so I was just confident in the
fact that you know I was gonna give them
something that nobody else had in the
four months so I just took it in stride
I guess yeah then it became a whole new
world yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when it comes to like a guy ritchie
movie you know there's gonna be amazing
action yes you also sing dancing you
have to do a lot so and then this is
such a beloved film by so many people so
many people grew up with it loved it
sort of talk to me about sort of the
biggest challenge or sort of what was
like the most daunting to you about
stepping into this this whole new world
I think you touched on it a little bit I
think it was just the amount of things
that I had to do in a very short amount
of time because casting took a while it
took away a little bit from the prep
time that we had so my days were just
packed with things that I had to you
know learn to do so this don't work
obviously is amazing and something that
I've had an amazing time doing and a lot
of fun and dancing and singing and camel
riding and I you know scuba diving a
little bit for really a scene in the
film I mean some of you may remember it
but just yeah the amount of things that
we kind of had to put together yeah but
on your resume because you know actors
put all these horse ridings always it
was it made it easier but they're
they're different creatures for sure
yeah
and then the music yes I've on my way
here I was listening to the soundtrack
the original soundtrack I can't wait for
this soundtrack to come out but you know
obviously there's these beloved song
[Music]
[Music]
there is do you have a particular one
that means the most to you and that is
your favorite overall yeah you know I
think one jump has a special place in my
heart because it's Aladdin's solo song
and it's kind of how we open the movie
and open the film but I think Naomi's
new song speechless in this film is
going to really wow people and I think
it's incredibly relevant in the times
that we live in and very empowering so
I'm looking forward to two people's
reactions on that and after being around
the music for so many months we're not
stuck in your head the most a whole new
world I guess because it's already stuck
in my head from my child right and yeah
and you know we'd really focused on
undelivered on that one as we did for
all of them but yeah okay so speaking of
music well Smith summons me I stand by
my oath to Jewish history I'm kidding
Russ is interview guys dude like behind
the scenes he was beatboxing yes I saw
some stuff on set where he like does
that quite often does he he beat boxes
he'd like raps he's like his yeah thing
all the time on say he riffs he's just
trying to bring the energy up you know
which he does as soon as he walks into a
room anyway
[Music]
we had a few scenes that we had to
improv in this film which I'm also very
excited for people to see cuz I like if
you would have told me five years ago I
would have got to improv with Will Smith
on this like massive film I would have
been like no I was nervous I was nervous
I actually it's funny he the first time
we met I think he thought I was one of
the dancers because I was in dance
rehearsals and I was really nervous I
came up to him and I was like I will and
I forgot to introduce myself so just
like oh hey man and then I was I walked
away and I was like he doesn't know who
I am like obviously we've never met you
can go yo Aladdin you look like a prince
on the outside but I didn't change
anything on the inside Showtime
no I'm in charge okay I say when it's
done like behind the scenes but you had
like the me know Will Smith highlight
reel yes what would be on the highlight
reel as like a favorite moment that you
will never share in another store
interviewer story ever I go I'm gonna
put it in the genie lamp over without
going into detail I guess me and will
and Jordan that was that was very
special when we went over to Jordan and
shot it was a very it was a reduced crew
a reduced cast and that was a lot of fun
he's a lot of fun things like that's all
you're gonna get right now no um you
know he he threw this magical party in
the desert in Wadi Rum and you know I'll
remember it for the rest of my life hey
can you make me a prince there is a lot
of gray area in make me a prince I could
just thank you a prince oh no I have to
ask you because in the trailer I haven't
seen the film yeah I can't wait to see
it but in the trailer there's a scene
and they think it's one of your wishes
where you say you want him to make you a
prince
right did you ever in one take say will
you make me a Fresh Prince
haha we had a play on words
lahter Simon I yeah yeah we threw that
in quite a bit yeah guessing it didn't
make the final yeah probably not no but
we threw it in a lot yeah and how is his
energy on set like how does he amazing
that amazing I couldn't have asked for a
better cast mate than will to do this
with and go on this journey with these
he's just amazing I mean he's kind and
down-to-earth and generous and and he's
really good in this village genie wishes
land
none of that ringing about cuz I don't
know at what stage in the process they
showed it to you yeah but what was your
reaction and when you saw your your boy
yeah I mean it's not really early
mock-ups so I got to see it pretty early
but then you know I I saw the film a
couple of weeks ago and it's looking
amazing it's looking at me it looks
spectacular yeah it does and those like
on that know Guy Ritchie one of my
favorite directors and he's just like
when I think of Guy Ritchie I think rock
and roll like he's a rock and roll
together he makes everything cooler yes
in a room he makes it cooler absolutely
and his sets I mean first of all his
actions amazing his visuals are amazing
so for fans and people who can't wait to
see this movie like what do you think
they're gonna take away from like a Guy
Ritchie Aladdin because I think like a
perfect combination yeah I think I think
you're spot on I think it is very cool
you know and I think what people
typically think of musicals they can
expect something a little different in
that it is a little bit more stylized
it's a little cooler it's a little
edgier so so yeah guy has definitely put
his his touch in it and I think it works
beautifully with this film and I think
the other thing everyone has to remember
is that guy specializes in telling
stories about thieves and crime and this
is a story about a thief ultimately what
do you think some of the other themes
are gonna be because there's obviously
like a theme of you know pretending
you're somebody or yeah personal
identity you know going on the journey
to find your identity which is something
that I went through and I'm still going
through and I think every human being
goes through that I think everyone
can relate to that idea falling in love
is another theme female empowerment is
another theme we're really focused on so
there's a lot of really relevant things
to take away from this film so did I
read that Robin Williams was one of the
reasons he became an actor yes place yes
no was it Aladdin Aladdin was definitely
one of them you know I I started acting
by doing voices for friends and family
and and that's a big aspect of a big
10,000 Jews will give you such a crick
in the neck Robin also does do a lot of
voice work and mrs. Doubtfire that was
another one in the rotations I've
probably seen that film more than any
other film my first day as a woman
getting hot flashes in my life that's
hard it's actually not his line in the
Fed okay she was the whole time the
whole time the whole time the whole time
we have to go we have to go I have to go
we have to go yeah he's amazing that oh
my gosh that's amazing
did you ever I mean in a million years
did you like growing up did you ever
think Aladdin like it was that ever
something that enter your mind before
you even heard about the casting run
probably yeah I mean Aladdin was one of
the few characters that I could relate
to growing up you know he looked like me
his culture was similar to mine and I
grew up in an Egyptian household so yeah
I think I've thought about it before for
sure I just never thought that I would
do a musical but again we've spoken
about that a little bit I think this is
different than your typical musical so
it makes sense for me and yes
I can grant you three wishes right now
oh man I think I love that question
I just
I mean hey where it's Fandango I would
say grant me the wish of going to see
this movie I think it's gonna really
affect people and I think they'll come
out of it
learning something about themselves and
aspiring to change something positively
in their life so that's what I would
wish for you to do so I know the tickets
go on sale on world wish day yes yes
they do
so tickets go on sale on world wish day
we're having an activation where if you
hashtag friend like me Disney's going to
donate five dollars to the make-a-wish
program so up to a million dollars so if
everyone hashtags and tags a couple of
their friends that they would like to
grant wishes for we could potentially be
donating a million dollars to the
program so that's important I'm so
excited for you I'm so excited for this
movie thank you I think everybody is
everybody can't wait it looks like a ton
of fun it's gonna be a ton of fun and
congratulations and thanks for the chat
thank you thanks for taking the time May
24 24
[Music]
you